audience questions they're still here
and they are stronger than ever by
audience demand we propose maybe
scrapping audience questions
furious audience members demanded that
they remain and we are obliging yeah
and I'm happy now I took audience
questions for granted all these years
and knowing that they're here to stay
and that that makes me feel happy right
no that's it you seem totally sincere
and honest and genuine when you said
that I really appreciate that Pat let's
get into the first question David what
should the sentence be for fake rape
allegations listen there if you're
asking me exactly what the sentence
should be in terms of a punishment the
law already says what it should be and
we'll get back to that in a second but
I've been reading a lot about
criminology lately and we often talk
about deterrent effects of criminal law
and an example of the debate that exists
there is you deter people from
committing murder if you have the death
penalty as a possibility versus just
having life in prison a potential
murderer is less likely to commit a
murder if they know they might get death
penalty instead of life in prison no
evidence of that
okay what the studies suggest is that
what really serves as a deterrent of
crime assuming that the punishment is
strict enough right like if the
punishment for murder was a year in
prison it's not going to work as a
deterrent what the studies show is a
good deterrent is a strict enough
potential punishment but a high
likelihood of getting caught okay so if
people believe that if they murder
someone it's likely relatively likely
what the percentage is that doesn't
matter but they need to believe that
it's likely that the police will catch
them and they will be prosecuted and
potentially be found guilty for the
murder that's what works as a deterrent
to get people not to murder if you are
believed if you are of the mindset that
is less likely that you will be caught
that will drastically increase someone's
propensity to murder death penalty
versus life in prison doesn't seem to
have a huge impact so when it comes to
the sentence for fake rape allegations I
am very
open to a relatively broad range of
sentences some people say it's got to be
a felony but it doesn't have to have the
same sentence as the rapist would have
gotten other people say no no no listen
if you make a fake rape allegation you
should be sentenced as if you had
committed the rape and were found guilty
about it there's a range there the
important thing is the person who's
gonna make a fake rape allegation needs
to feel as though it's likely they will
get caught and and punished the exact
punishment is less important as long as
it's serious enough do people feel as
though if they make fake rape
allegations they are likely to get
caught I genuinely don't know the answer
those fake allegations are relatively
rare yeah I think so because what's the
what do you get out of that I mean is it
some attention that you're trying to
seek out is it that you are enemies with
this person and you want to lock them up
I think it happens very few and far
between what the sentence should be I
don't know maybe maybe 20% of what the
accused rapist would get all of them
like that so if they were to be locked
away for 10 years you get two years if
they're locked away for you know my
mouth gonna get tough here but five
years get six months something like that
that one year am i being overly punitive
if I say that that feels a little bit
low to me 20 percent if you can by your
virtue of a lie put someone at risk of
spending 20 years in prison if you made
it up you should only get four I mean I
just don't know I'm just not sure about
that but it but again the real you got
an interesting thing which is why might
someone make a fake rape allegation
obviously we're not talking here about
misidentification we're talking about
genuine just I accuse someone I know it
didn't really do it it can be a personal
vendetta against someone it can be a
mental illness it can be misplaced
trauma something did happen to you and
you pick someone out and that's who
you're going to blame knowingly although
again these are very rare phenomena and
really the problem for me is way too few
actual rapists end up being convicted
that's the real problem both from lack
of reporting and from the sometimes
inherent difficult difficulties of
proving some of those
so the sentence for fake rape
allegations must be sufficiently high
that it is somewhat of a deterrent and
most importantly people need to feel
that it's likely that if they make a
fake allegation they're going to get
caught that is a really good deterrent
for people committing a certain crime or
participating in a certain act send me
your thoughts if you have something more
specific in mind